الزعيم عادل امام الزعيم عادل امام يحتفل
بعيد ميلاده ثالث وثمانين واستحاله مستمره
من الغياب المثير للجدل ثلاث سنوات لم
يحضر فيها الزعيم على شاشات السينما او
التلفزيون جعلت الجماهير تتساءل عن
امكانيه رؤيته في عمل جديد قريبا اقرباء
الزعيم عادل امام اكدوا ان احتفال بميلاد
هذا العام سيقتصر على اسره بعيدا عن
الاضواء في حين تستمر التاكيدات انه يتمتع
بصحه جيده وربما يعود الى الشاشه قريبا
طبعا كانت اخر اعمال الزعيم عام 2020 حين
قدم مسلسل فالنتينو بمشاركه الراحله دلال
عبد العزيز والراحل سمير صبري المزيد حول
المسيره الفنيه الطويله للفنان القدير
عادل امام مع الزميل علاء سرحان علاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اه ده جاي لي انا بقى
[موسيقى]
بتقول لي اقف
بعد 14 سنه خدمه في ثانوي بتقول لي اه
ثلاثه
عمره الفنان عادل امام قضى منها اكثر من
60 عاما في عالم التمثيل في جميع مجالاته
من الشاشه الكبيره او الصغيره وحتى على
خشبه المسرح ليكون بالفعل زعيمه المهنه
التي احبها ومنحها كل امكانياته ما يزيد
عن 100 فيلم سينمائي قدمها الزعيم عادل
امام ابرزها الارهاب والكباب بخيط عديله
الحريف والواد الواد محروس بتاع الوزير
وايضا السفاره في العماره كذلك قدم الزعيم
نحو احدى عشره مسرحيه على مدى سنوات ظلت
تعليقه في عقول وقلوب الجماهير منها مدرسه
المشاغبين الواد سيد الشغال ومسرحيه
الزعيم وطبعا شاهد ما شافش حاجه وكانت
المسرحيه الاخيره له بعنوان بودي جارد
وعلى الشاشه الصغيره قدم الزعيم سته عشره
مسلسلا تلفزيونيا تراوحت بين الدراما
والكوميديا اخرها مسلسل فالنتينو عام 2020
كذلك ساهم في مسلسل اذاعي برفقه عبد
الحليم حافظ عام
1973 حمل عنوان ارجوك لا تفهمني بسرعه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات